So now that we have a working asset manager it's probably worth taking a step
back and talking about how good asset loading works in good games. See, proper
asset loading means you need to take into account how a user's going to
experience your game and benefit from that properly. So for instance, if you
were on a CDROM drive you have to know that it's going to take a certain amount
of time to actually stream data from the disc into memory. So, you have to
pretty much cover that by doing some 3 second animation or something else to
hide from the user, that's streaming overhead. Now, some very interesting
examples of this come to mind. The first is probably one of the more famous
ones, Devil May Cry, back on the original PlayStation 2. This game had a really
cool mode, that while the scene was actually loading, if you did your button
smashing, you'd actually do damage to the loading bar. I actually remember
sitting in my room watching my roommate kind of smash on this button controller
as mad as possible, because he was so angry that it was taking so long to load.
But by the time the level actually loaded, he was happy again and could go on
killing all sorts of demons. The second example that comes to mind is actually
Metroid Prime for the Game Cube. This was actually a simplistic tunnel shooter,
effectively you had segments of geometry that your player would move through
over time. They did something really cool, is that they only allowed one
section of tunnel in memory at a time. This meant that each tunnel could be
super high resolution graphics because there was nothing else competing for
space. As you moved towards the end of the tunnel, though, towards one of those
little doors you've got to shoot to open, it would start streaming in the next
level. The problem with this though was if you started running too fast, you
would get to the door before the streaming was done. You'd sit there shooting
the door and it wouldn't open yet because the next level hadn't loaded. My
personal favorite is actually Jak and Daxter. These guys had probably one of
the earliest streaming mechanisms that I ever found. And the coolest way to
hide it too. They had an infinite terrain. So you could run around and do all
sorts of stuff. But if you for some reason were able to move fast enough that
you were moving in an area that the terrain hadn't been streamed off a disk
yet, they'd trip your player. This is the only time in the entire game where
your player would actually fall down, and then play a 3 to 4 second get up
animation. Of course during that time they had plenty of extra space to spit up
the rest of the data from the disk. The point is this, most of game development
is smoke and mirrors, so take advantage of that to give your user a believable
experience.